the democratic football lads alliance
end the march
among them in the center here wearing a
suit is the ukip leader
gerard batten sky news is the only
broadcaster present
and we're not invited
no trouble
[Music]
it doesn't feel like no trouble
[Music]
ahead a row of police are hoping to
separate them from a group of
anti-racism protesters
[Music]
the football lads alliance tried to
break through
they are supposedly here to peacefully
demonstrate against the rape of women
and children by muslim gangs
[Music]
but it doesn't turn out to be peaceful
keep moving
the football lads alliance was formed by
a football hooligan to unite supporters
from different clubs against islam
its facebook page has been criticized
for racist content
and the group has since renamed itself
the democratic football lads alliance
so who are these people none of us are
racist i'm an edl member
i'm a tommy robinson boy i'm sick of the
corrupt government telling us lies
blacking out
they're doing blackouts on news media
look what's happening in paris
france germany sweden all the things
that were reported look
all things no they weren't reporting on
correctly they weren't reported on
correctly are you from what
is going on sky news oh the biggest
liars out there
so why don't you report accurate news
why don't you report about all the rapes
that are going on all the islamic
terrorism that's going you know full
well what's going on we have reported on
terrorist attacks
and we have reported on what's been
going on why why'd you label
these cities how else would you know why
do you label people like like
why do you let them say why do
[Music]
we asked the counter protesters why they
think the group is racist
what's your problem with these guys
they're racist
why they say they're just protesting
against rape they do yeah but they need
a moral cover
don't they we stand with the victims of
rape
who could be any color from
any religion or any nationality
they're only interested in having a go
at muslims
that's the new form of racism if we
allow it to divide us
we're shocked so what is the leader of
ukip
doing here this is a football lads
alliance march i mean how do you feel
associating ukip's name with that
they've all i've already given talks to
their groups lots of them have joined us
they are democratic
uh as you can see they're against
extremism of any kind
so i don't have a problem with it there
have been issues around racist comments
on their website
calling for sadiq khan to be hanged for
example right
on your facebook page so all you're
going to do now is try to
disparage what we're doing put out some
more fake news so
i didn't
you'll raise some issue that's not
relevant there's this gentleman told he
told you they don't have a website they
do have a website
page that's how we knew this that's how
we knew this was happening you go off
and you say whatever you want to say
and i'll do my stuff here if you answer
that you don't it's fair i do not
answer that question which question
which you presumably condemn
things such as i do i've spent 25 years
running being a member of a moderate
party you're now running a moderate
party
a democratic party we've always said
that always done that you cannot control
individuals saying stupid things they do
it in all parties
so that's the end of the interview thank
you but why when you why when you're
enough why when you've got
the former ukip leader thinks this is an
unnecessary distraction for the party
my concern with all of these groups is
that that argument spills over
into actually being an enemy of an
entire religion and that is not
the place we need to be for every reason
it's the wrong thing to do and it won't
work anyway
do you fear that that's what gerald
batten is falling down that track
well i don't think he's there yet but i
think he's going to be careful what
company he keeps
back at the rally mr baton had this to
say about muslim grooming gangs
so the age of consent in islamic culture
is a lot more elastic than it would be
in western people here insist that
they're not fascist they don't like to
be called far
right but the overriding view is that
muslims are dangerous
and that immigration is bad and this
does feel like a reincarnation
of the edl but it's also got the leader
of ukip gerald batten
on the stage and what he's saying is
pretty much
indistinguishable from what you might
hear from tommy robinson
indeed gerard batten wants the former
edl leader to join his party
unfortunately we were forcibly stopped
from recording the whole of his speech
[Music]
but this weekend at ukip's party
conference delegates will decide whether
to reverse rules
to ban former members of far-right
groups from joining uk
that would change the face of the party
and give anti-muslim sentiment
a new home jason farrell sky news